Was genau befindet sich eigentlich am rand unseres sonnensystems
eine äußerst spannende frage zu der forschungsteams weltweit tüfteln
jetzt hat die nasa eine erfolgsmeldung in diesem zusammenhang ausgaben denn ihre sonde new horizons hat wohl diese lang gesuchte struktur
aufgespürt die grenze zwischen unserem sonnensystem und dem interstellaren raum alle infos dazu
bekommt ihr jetzt mal klick zum science fiction herzlich willkommen
Und damit herzlich willkommen zum ersten
werbefreien video hier auf klicks um tausend dank an alle mitglieder des kanals die das möglich gemacht haben wie zum beispiel steven maurer
mitglied werden könnt erfahrt ihr am ende des videos
die nasa sonde new horizons
war im januar 2006 gestartet um unter anderem den pluto zu erforschen aber auch die genaue untersuchung der heliosphäre
steht auf ihrem plan damit ist die atmosphäre der sonne gemeint die eine große region um die sonne bezeichnet in der
sonnenwind samt seiner magnetfelder wirksam ist die äußerste grenze der heliosphäre ist die sogenannte heliopause
oft auch als grenze unseres sonnensystems bezeichnet und dahinter beginnt dann laut definition der
interstellaren raum new horizons ist derzeit jedenfalls auf dem weg zur grenze unseres sonnensystems
dieses zu passieren dass haben bisher nur die beiden voyager sonden geschafft und das will schon was heißen denn es müssen nicht nur gigantische
dimensionen
entfernungen überwunden werden sondern auch die gravitation der sonne dazu hatten die deutsche sondern mehrere swing by manöver durchgeführt
und insgesamt haben sie für die ganze mission mehr als 25 jahre gedacht wow
und schon damals hatte deutsche entdeckung gemacht die auf das ende unseres sonnensystems hinweisen genau wie jetzt new horizons in den jahren
2007 und
2017 die sondelfinger einen
ultravioletten schimmer 1 nach ansicht der forschungsteams wohl von solaren photonen produziert die auf wasserstoffatome
treffen und sich zerstreuen schon damals gab es die theorie dass es sich bei dieser gigantischen struktur am rande unseres sonnensystems
um eine wasserstoff wand handeln könnte und auch auf eine aktuelle aufnahme hat ein nasa forschungsteam jetzt ein
ultraviolettes leuchten ende also ein weiteres starkes indiz dafür eine wasserstoff wand als das ende des
sonnensystems spricht doch wie entsteht das ultraviolette leuchten dazu schreibt das nasa forschungsteam das beobachtete
ultraviolette licht ist nicht nur das ergebnis der zerstreuung das sonnenlicht durch wasserstoff atome im sonnensystem
sondern deutet auch auf eine entfernte quelle in die entfernte quellen könnte der beweis für eine band aus
wasserstoff sein die in der nähe der stelle entdeckt wurde wo der
interstellare wind mit dem sonnenwind in berührung kommt also noch mal im klartext
sonnenwinde entstehen dadurch dass die sonne ständig geladene teilchen ausstrahlt dieser teilchenstrom samt seinem magnetfeld erzeugt die heliosphäre
der teilchenstrom der sonne verdrängt hier
das interstellare medium doch mit zunehmendem abstand von der sonne wird der sonnenwind verständlicherweise immer schwächer er kann dann den strom
interstellarer teilchen nicht mehr stoppen hier befindet sich
eine art grenze ihre außenseite zeigt in die richtung in der sich die sonne durchs all bewegt genau hier
kommt es dann zum stau von interstellarer materie die auch wasserstoff enthält wenn diese wasserstoff atome dann auf geladene partikel
aus dem sonnenwind treffen senden sie und ra violettes licht aus doch der endgültigen beweis für diese
wasserstoff wand der steht noch aus so die nasa denn das ultraviolette licht könnte theoretisch auch noch aus anderen
quellen in den tiefen der galaxis stammen doch genau das soll new horizons jetzt ausschließen und weiter
nach dem schimmern ausschau halten wenn das ultraviolette licht aber weiterhin bestehen bliebe
handele es sich wohl um eine quelle vor der sonne und sei dann nicht als hinweis auf das ende unseres
sonnensystems zu deuten so und jetzt könnt ihr krieg zum weiter werbefrei machen
keine privates mehr mit eurer hilfe
immer wenn wir entsprechend viele kanal mitglieder gewonnen haben schalten wir die werbung vor jeweils einem video im monat ab das hier ist das erste
video und es werden mehr werdet also mitglied hier unter dem video
draufklicken und bekommt noch exklusive extra videos exklusive live streams und noch ein paar weitere privilegien
einen diesen dank all diejenigen die schon dabei sind wenn er immer garantiert über aktuelle videos informiert werden wollten dann endet mich übrigens bei whatsapp
dann bekommt ihr den link zum video vor allen andern von mir persönlich auf euer handy einfach hier draufklicken
und darunter geht es weiter mit dem auftreten erster
interstellare mission verlässt unserem sonnensystem bis dann
bleibt dran